This video is made possible by the freeze play action game. Cross out,
check out the game through the link in the description below,
and you can start with three extra weapons or a vehicle cabin just for
registering
Francis Drake, the English.
Remember as a hero who made nautical history and enabled that country's maritime
dominance, the Spanish. Remember in his El DRAC the dragon,
the man who ravaged that colonies and destroyed their Armada. As you'll soon,
find out there are valid reasons to dislike frog's history.
Especially when looked at through a modern lens.
He was ruthless and authoritarian. When it came to commanding his ships,
he was involved in slavery for awhile,
and he took part in at least one massacre,
but there is no way to deny his many accomplishments and the long-term effects
they had on history.
As Francis Drake firmly established himself as one of the greatest and the most
daring Naval commanders and explorers in history.
Three.
The strike was born second of 15,
14 near Tavistock and the English County of Devin's Edmunds and
Mary Drake, the oldest of 12 siblings.
His father had been a sailor in his used before being ordained as a minister and
to some soon followed in his steps.
Edmonds found Francis his first position to board a ship when he was a teenager.
And by the time he turned 18,
Francis Drake had already been made the passer of a ship sailing to the Bay of
Biscay, the person who was the person who handled the money.
So while not a position that required skill and experience,
it did show the amount of trust that was placed in young Drake.
When he was 20 years old,
Francis Drake made his first long distance voyage traveling to the coast of
Guinea in West Africa, a border slaving vessel.
They belonged to one of England's most prominent Naval commanders at the time,
John Hawkins Hawkins at the dubious distinction of being considered England's
first slave trader,
who overcame his own country's laws by collecting slaves from Africa and selling
them to Spanish colonies in the new world.
He also happens to be an older cousin of Drake and took the young sailor under
his wing as his protege.
All of this was happening during the outset of the age of discovery.
A period in European history marked by exploration global trade and colonial
empires.
Naval dominance has never been more important since it was simply impossible to
become a global power without having a strong Navy,
the most powerful fleet at the time in Europe,
at least belonged to Spain who were England's sworn enemy,
even though the two countries were not engaged in open war. Not yet anyway,
but there was a lot of private hearing going on,
meaning that private ships sent permission from their governments do engage
enemy vessels in battle without fear of repercussions.
Drake's first transatlantic voyage occurred around 1566 when he sailed aboard a
private hearing fleet owned by Hawkins and captains by John Lovell.
They first went to West Africa again,
where they attacked Portuguese slave ships in coastal towns. Afterwards,
they sailed to the Americas where they sold the slaves,
do plantations and return to England with their cargo holds full of gold sugar
hides and precious metals.
Technically this wasn't allowed since most of the colonies in the new world
belong to Spain and they did not allow trade with the English boss as always
money spoke the loudest.
And there were plenty of Spanish outposts willing to ignore the edict and do
some business. This was a profitable trip for Hawkins. So unsurprisingly,
he scheduled another one for the following year.
This time he had a fleet of six ships headed by Hawkins himself,
a bolt dominion, Frances Dre.
He could also risen through the ranks ends on this voyage.
He was captain of his own ship Bach called the Judith.
The journey started off as the previous ones. First,
the fleet went to West Africa to collect slaves and then headed for America to
sell them once their business was complete, the ships were ready to return home,
but they encountered a powerful storm off the coast of Florida.
They were too damaged to make the transatlantic journey.
So instead they sailed to a nearby port to repair and resupply.
The posing question was San Juan Lujan today,
part of the city of Veracruz and Mexico. Soon after they pulled into Harbor,
a powerful Spanish fleet arrived,
which contains the Viceroy of new Spain himself,
Don Martin on recasts the situation was very tense,
but after days of negotiations, it seems like a pact was reached,
which would allow the English ships to leave the port on harms.
This was not to be though because the Viceroy broke the pack since attacked to
the English fleet. They quickly turned into a sorter.
The English lost four of the six ships, 500 men.
And most of that plunder only the Judith and the minion managed to escape.
But this was only after they abandoned more men on the coast to ease the burden.
The battle had a significant impact on the already strange relationship between
England and Spain, the Spanish Viceroy considered this.
He acted justly since what Hawkins was doing was technically piracy.
So he had every right to engage them in combat in waters,
over which he claimed sovereignty. The English.
On the other hand is considered a scornful act of treachery and Drake in
particular developed a hatred for all things, Spanish and vowed revenge.
[Inaudible].
That Boeing's on Francis Drake dedicated himself to privateering well focusing
solely on Spanish targets, despite his relative lack of experience,
he was given commission of two ships, the dragon and the Swan,
and found no shortage of volunteers willing to take on Spain in 1517,
he set off on his first independent voyage and then another one the following
year, but only aboard the SWAT. He sailed to the West Indies both times.
Although what he did that is unclear if he did engage in any Naval combat,
it wasn't anything major, more likely.
These missions were intended to gather information on the strength of the enemy
in the region and to show the people back home,
that it was possible to sail these treacherous waters and returned to England
safe and sound dregs.
First genuine privateering expedition took place in 1572 when he decided to
launch raids on the isthmus of Panama,
which connected North and South America and its surrounding areas that region,
which the Spanish cooled Terrafirma Drake set sail on March the 24th.
He had two ships at his, the 25 tons Swan, and they knew a larger vessel.
The 70 ton patch up Drake, and they had a small crew of 73 men and boys,
but he supplemented his forces by using the old adage.
The enemy of my enemy is my friends in South America.
He allied himself with former African slaves.
He managed to escape that capitalism live as Outlaws.
The Spanish golden Semaron meaning wild or unruly, although to the English,
they became known as the Maroons.
These men had a large presence in the area and sometimes work together with the
English and French pirates bonding over their mutual hatred of the Spanish
English privateer arrived in Panama in July and launched a raid on the town of
number dos. It was a small targets.
That's an important one because the Spanish used it as a port of call to
transfer their loot from that treasure fleet in the Pacific ocean to galleons
waiting in the Caribbean seat. Unfortunately for Drake, his timing was off,
even though he was successful in sacking the town.
He did it when there was no John shipments of precious metals waiting to be
taken to Spain. Not only did he find nothing to blunder,
but he also sustained a serious injury during the attack,
which forced him to abandon naan bread, to deals and returned to his ship.
Soon after that, there is a popular story from this event,
which said that while in town,
Drake climbs up a tree and saw the Pacific ocean for the first time.
And it was a foreshadowing swore that he would one day sail those waters.
This was also the time when Francis Drake met Diego,
a former slave who would join his crew and go on to become one of the most
useful and loyal many hats right off the bat.
Diego proved his worth by organizing a meeting between Drake and Pedro Mandingo,
the leader of a local simmer and group,
and this secured a valuable Alliance for the English privateers with the help of
Drake was able to set up a Fort on a small Island in the Gulf of sun blasts off
the coast of Panama,
which he used as his base of operations for the following year.
Occasionally launching minor raids against the Spanish,
but mostly waiting for the opportune time to get a big score in honor,
of his new resourceful friends, Drake named it forced Diego.
Also during this time,
Drake secured another ally in the form of a French privateer named Gillum.
The tester that big school finally came in April 15, 73,
almost a year after Drake at first arrived in Panama together as the English,
the French and the Cimarron plugs at the Spanish silver train mule train route
used to transport golden silver across the SMS in order to ship it to Spain,
the precious cargo was protected by almost 200 Spanish soldiers,
but the elements of surprise gave the edge to the attackers.
Even if they were outnumbered,
the loot proved to be far beyond their expectations.
The whole was around 30 tons of golden silver.
It was so much treasure that the privateers and the Cimarron couldn't even carry
it all and to have to bury part of it and the banks of a nearby river,
hoping they might one day return. Not everyone got to enjoy the plunge.
The test died soon after the battle,
the French privateer was initially injured during the fighting.
Then he ended a couple of his men stayed behind to rest for a while before
catching up to the rest of the party.
They'd all got a little bit too long though.
And a second Spanish force ran into them and executed them on the spot.
As far as Drake was concerned,
his mission in Panama was competed and he soon returned to England with 20,000
pounds in golden Silva. Becca Drake was regarded by many as a hero,
but they could not acknowledge his privateering efforts officially since in the
meantime,
England and Spain inside a temporary truce and the English government had
promised to stop any kind of support for privateers rating Spanish territories
in the new Wells.
This also meant that Drake had to find something else to do for the time being.
So queen Elizabeth asked him to take part in a new program.
She initiated called the enterprise of all step basically is involved,
convincing English entrepreneurs to set up new businesses in areas of Ireland,
where there were still an armed resistance.
Drake was supposed to help keep the peace,
but he ended up doing the exact opposite.
There are two events that will forever tarnish Drake's legacy.
The first we already talked about,
and that was his involvement in the slave trade during his first years as a
sailor. The second was his role in one of the worst massacres in Irish history,
known as the Rathlin Island massacre Rosslyn castle on the eponymous Island
was used as a hiding place and base of operations for the Irish resistance led
by the McDonald's of Antrim. In fact,
it was considered so safe that other groups sent their families there as well.
However, Henry Sydney law, deputy of Ireland as appointed by queen Elizabeth,
heard of this stronghold and wanted it eliminated as a threat.
He sent two forces,
one led by dragons the other by sir John Norris to storm the castle after
battering the wolves with Canada,
Vajra it became clear that the Irish resistance had no chance of winning.
So they surrendered despite this,
the attack has executed all the remaining soldiers and when they were finished,
they hunted down and slaughtered around 400 civilians who mainly consisted of
women, children, the sick and the elderly Drake's precise role is uncertain.
As some of his defenders argue that the actual massacre was committed by Nerys
and his men, while Drake stayed behind on his ship to ensure that no resistance
reinforcements came to the Island. And look,
if you're looking for a grand adventure links of Francis drags,
and you might want to check out today, sponsor cross out.
Now you might not be able to build your own English on modern dominate the seas.
But if you want to build your own vehicle and pit yourself against other people,
then cross out is the game for you cross out.
Isn't one of those allegedly customizable games where it's like, yeah, yeah,
you get to choose the type of Amarone on a games. Customizable.
This is a full on customizable competition.
You're given a basic hunk of metal and then you make all the remaining decisions
for yourself. So stick on some rail guns, stick on a rocket booster. Awesome.
Mama runs off you, go on your journey way, build it well, and you will dominate,
build it badly. And you, well, probably just won't work out for you,
but there are easy ways to avoid that.
It's a super fast pace game with loads of different game modes,
and you've got pretty much limitless freedom to create.
And what you do with your vehicle is entirely up to you.
Also a major plus is that it's not complicated, right? From the start.
You can just start up the game and you'll be battling in no time,
no learning the ropes, just immediate gameplay.
But then as you get used to the game,
you can then to mascaras join us on the battlefield for free using the link in
the description below PC X-Box one PS4 easy,
and going through that and link against you,
a free start snatch with three extra weapons or a vehicle cabin all is just a
bonus for registering and doing that is really the best way that you can support
what we're doing. Yeah.
The biographics our sponsors really do make this whole thing possible.
So thanks to cross out and let's get back to the video.
[Inaudible].
Years later, Drake gold, the private hearing itch. Again,
he sold enough time had passed and that it was okay for him to start attacking
the Spanish once more and well queen Elizabeth agreed, not even the, of course,
but the queen ends many influential members of her course funded a new
expedition for Drake larger and more ambitious than before.
Drake had five ships at his command.
The flagship was a 120 ton galleon named the Pelican,
which drank later renamed to the golden Hinz in the middle of the journey to
honor one of his patrons officially this enterprise was branded a voyage of
discovery, Drake plans that navigate the straits of Magellan,
the first Englishman to do so, and then explore the Pacific ocean. In reality,
this was a rating expedition and Drake fully intended to attack every Spanish
town and ship that he met along the way in an effort to weaken the control that
Spain had on the Pacific coast of the Americas.
His original plan was to keep going North once he was in the Pacific and
hopefully find a way back to the Atlantic by crossing the Arctic ocean.
Of course, Drake did not know this at the time,
but what he was referring to was the treacherous Northwest passage that passed
through the Canadian Arctic archipelago.
It would be another 300 years before that route would be navigated for the first
time by Roldan Munson and other pioneering Explorer,
who we've already covered here at biographics.
So maybe you check out that video if you haven't already. Anyway,
Drake ended up making it further up North than any previous European,
but he obviously had no business trying to navigate the Arctic ocean.
So he had no choice,
but to keep heading West crossing the whole Pacific and then the Indian
oceans rounding the Cape of good hope in Africa.
And then finally sailing the Atlantic ocean. Once more,
as a consequence of this Francis Drake's expedition became the second in history
to circle the globe. After the NASA Ferdinand Magellan 55 years earlier,
Drake became the first commander to lead an entire circumnavigation because
although we often say the Magellan completed the first circumnavigation in
history, this is only partially correct. His expedition completed this,
but Magellan himself did not.
He was killed in the Philippines and one of his officers harmed Sebasty and Al
Cano let the rest of the journey, but we're getting ahead of ourselves.
We know how it was going to end. Let's get back to the start of Trix voyage.
He set sail from Plymouth on December the 15th, 1577, after a lengthy delay,
he first began to do a bit of action. You know,
the Cape Verde islands off the Northwest point of Africa,
where he plundered Spanish and Portuguese ships even added one to his fleet.
Renaming it's the Mary from its original center, Maria,
his most valuable addition, however,
was a Portuguese pilot named know-how to Silva who was experienced in navigating
the South American waters and to agree to help Drake on his voyage,
upon reaching South America, Drake decided to make landfall in port St.
Julian today, part of Argentina,
the same place where Magellan had landed 58 years prior here,
the problem started piling up due to heavy losses on his crossing of the
Atlantic ocean Drake no longer had the manpower to maintain six ships.
So he decided to scuttle two of his smaller vessels. Meanwhile,
in this new edition, the Mary, it turns out to have rotting woods.
So they broke it for parts and burn the rest down.
And just as long as that is sick ship fleet was reduced to three,
but his biggest problem came in the form of officer Thomas doubty doubty started
off as one of Drake's most valuable men, even being given command of the Mary.
At one point, however,
during the Atlantic crossing the relationship between the two men took a drastic
turn for the worst of first downs was demoted, then placed under house arrest.
And then finally convicted on charges of witchcraft sons penalty of death Dowty
was executed in the same spot when the gellan did the same with mutineers about
his own ship. The message was pretty clear.
Drake was the one in charge here and he would not tolerate any challenges to his
authority even. So Dante's execution caused quite a stir back in England.
And even now scholars argue whether Drake was in the right or if it was a
flagrant abuse of power waltzing through the Strait of Magellan caused even more
problems.
One of the three remaining ships was lost along with everyone on board.
And another one became separated in a storm and got so badly damaged that it's
men demanded.
They had back home upon emerging in the Pacific old Drake now have,
was this flagship, the golden Hinze and less than half of the crew,
he started with things looked pretty grim for him,
but he soon found a measure of good fortune because the Spanish had completely
dominated the waters on the Pacific coast for decades.
Nobody was really expecting an English rating party,
almost all the merchant ships and the coastal towns,
Drake plundered were taken by surprise and nearly defenseless.
It wasn't this time that Drake took the richest prize of his career,
a treasure galleon names, the nitrous,
and Nora did it Concepcion better known by the colorful moniker of [inaudible].
Eventually the Spanish learned of Drake's presence and sends a fleet after him,
but then have a quarter up to the golden hinders.
It traveled up North reaching the upper coast of California upon making landfall
Drake names, the bland Nova Albion, new Albion and themed for queen Elizabeth.
The first, he didn't actually leave anyone to form a colony though,
because he couldn't spare the manpower.
And it's the actual location of new Albion became a subject of debate for
centuries today.
The U S government officially recognizes port as California as Drake's landing
spot and designated. It it's a national historic landmark.
Once he realized there was no way to cross the Atlantic up North Drake kept
sailing westerns unintentionally circumnavigated the globe.
Once he was out of Spanish waters, the biggest danger had passed,
but he still encountered a few perils.
Sometimes the natives were hostile to him. Also most turned out to be friendly,
especially in India and Indonesia, but one occasion,
his ship got stuck in a reef and he had to literally throw tons of ownable cargo
overboard to lighten the load.
He also lost his trusted sidekick Diego during that part of the trip,
as he died from wounds previously sustained in South America while fighting them
or push people along mocker islands. But for the most part,
it was smooth sailing until Drake was back in England on September the 26th,
1580 there,
he discovered that most people had assumed that he and his entire crew had
perished.
And he could not be given a proper celebration because the English ground could
not officially acknowledge his actions against Spain, even.
So the voyage had been an astounding success,
not just from a historical point of view, but a financial one as well.
It's estimated that Drake's supporters got paid back 47 pounds for every one
pounds. They invested a profit return of 4600%.
Drake himself became incredibly rich and powerful and was knighted by queen
Elizabeth a year later
For the next few years.
Drake settled down for a bit serving as the mayor of Plymouth and does a member
of parliament in 1595. However,
all pretenses of peace between England and Spain were dropped and war broke out
between the two nations. It was only a matter of time,
really ends now Francis Drake was free to go private hearing again,
launching a preemptive strike against the Spanish colonies of the new world.
He mainly focused his efforts on port towns located in modern day Columbia and
the Dominican Republic as most notable action during this time actually had
nothing to do with the war, but with the notorious colony of Roanoke,
England's first failed attempt to do permanent settlement in North America.
Drake passed by Roanoke islands on his way back and found the colonists
starving.
He took most of them back to England while the ones who stayed behind were never
heard from again,
the tanks in the new worlds did not concern Spain too much because King Phillip,
the second set a much more ambitious plan in mind,
he was preparing to invade England by mid 1597. He was almost ready,
but it was Francis Dre who again, foiled his plans.
Drake was busy attacking Spanish trade routes,
trying to cause as much disruption as possible in April, 1587.
He arrived at the poor city of CodeHS,
where he founds a large Spanish fleet and tons of supplies sitting in
anticipation of the invasion with the elements of surprise on his side,
Drake took his own fleet and launched a daring attack on April the 29th against
the ships waiting in the Harbor because raid was a massive success is great
managed to sync around 30 Spanish ships while Boonie losing one,
not to mention all the supplies that were destroyed and all the other vessels he
plundered during this expedition,
all in all this delayed the Spanish invasion for about a year.
And it became mockingly known in England as singeing, the King of Spain's Viet.
But even with this success,
Drake still knew that a full-scale attack on England was inevitable on may the
28, 1588,
the Spanish Armada set sail for the English channel comprising 130 ships
carrying 18,000 soldiers and 8,000 sailors.
The English had a hundred vessels at their disposal commanded by Lord Charles
Howard with Drake serving as his vice Admiral,
the Spanish intended to focus on Malai battle.
Thus employing that powerful inventory by dropping them off on lands and by
boarding enemy ships, the English and long range cannons.
So they preferred to keep this fight at a distance as much as possible.
Even when the Amada made landfall in Kalai,
the English forced them back into open water by sending far ships into their
midst and then bombarding them with Canon fire. Once more,
the definitive battle happens near grave lines on August the eighth.
It lasted only a little over eight hours, but the English were victorious.
The Spanish Armada might've been able to regroup and launch a new attack where
it not for incredibly bad weather,
powerful winds for citizens in the middle of the North sea and with the English
fleet behind it, it couldn't turn around and go home. Instead,
it had to take the long way rounds, rounding Scotland and Ireland,
continuous storms sank many more ships while others were around aground ground
on the shore, combine this with disease and lack of supplies.
And the return voyage caused far more casualties to Spain than the actual
flight. Only about 2000 Spanish soldiers died fighting the English,
but by the time the I'm automated back home,
almost half of the ships had been lost. And around 15,000 men.
The diet.
This was another giant feather in Drake's cap buzz.
It was the last one he'll ever get. He still has a few good years left,
but it all went quickly downhill from that a year later in 1589,
England launched the Drake Norris expedition popularly called the English or
counter Armada. Its purpose was clear permanently cripple,
Spain as a Naval power by destroying what remained of its fleet and also provide
aid to the Portuguese who were at the time rebelling against King Philip.
This endeavor sent down to be what some considered the greatest Naval disaster
in English history. First Drake chose to attack the city of at Karuna.
Although his exact reasoning is unclear.
Some say he may have believed a legend that the city tower held a vast gold
treasure.
He destroyed the ships in the Harbor and plundered the village easily enough,
but failed to capture the fortress and lost thousands of men in the siege before
being forced to retreat.
Then he went to Lisbon where the infantry bled by Norris was supposed to support
Portuguese rebels, but was soundly defeated by the Spanish Garrison. Lastly,
Drake wanted to sail to the Azores to intercept interceptor, treasure fleets,
but powerful storms forced him back to England.
By the time Drake made it back home,
he had sustained losses that rivaled those of the Spanish Armada things went
from bad to worse for Drake.
As he tried to go back to his roots with another privateering campaign in South
America, maybe it was his advanced age to blame this.
The man who had previously been so successful could not buy a victory anymore.
He suffered one defeat after another,
both on land and on the sea after failings or plans of the port of Panama Drake
fellow with dysentery and early 1596,
he died a few weeks later on January the 28th aged around 55.
Drake was buried at sea off the coast of portabello,
allegedly in and deadlines coffin while wearing a full suit of armor near at the
wrecks of two of his ships.
The shipwrecks have been located in modern times and divers think is only a
matter of time until they also discover the final resting place of Francis
Drake, the dragon. So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
Please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to subscribe,
check it off. Fantastic sponsor. Cross out, link below. Thank you for watching.